In this section, we'll be adding code to our Blueprint actor within the Blueprint's
Event Graph.
The Event Graph executes commands at runtime during gameplay.
So back on our project, I have the BP Sequence Trigger Box example open, and I'm under
the Event Graph tab.
So the first thing we need to do is ensure that the BP Bot, which is our main
character, is the only actor that can trigger the sequence.
We'll do this by adding a Cast To node after the actor Begin Overlap.
So to do that, I'm going to drag off of the Event Actor Begin Overlap, and just start
typing Cast To BP Bot.
There we have our Cast To BP Bot.
Next we're going to drag off this other actor and select the object.
Compile and Save.
We should be good to go.
Now next, from the Cast To BP Bot, we'll need to add a Set Actor Enable Collision node and
set it to false.
So to do that, we can just drag off of this, and we'll do Set Actor Collision.
So there's our Set Actor Enable Collision, drag off of this, and we'll see that our
new Actor Enable Collision is set to false.
This is what we want.
This will ensure that the BP Bot actor won't retrigger the event again once it's been
activated.
A quick note here is as you're dragging off, if you don't see the Set Actor, you can
uncheck Context Sensitive to see all of the nodes that are available.
Context Sensitive is just a nice way of the engine filtering out results that typically
work with this actor, but sometimes it gets it right, sometimes it doesn't.
Go ahead and hit Compile.
Now the next thing we're going to do is create a new Level Sequence Actor object
reference variable called Main Sequence.
So underneath the variables, let's click our plus, a new variable, and let's just
call this Main Sequence.
Now in my case, you can see that it did select it, but if your shows as, say, for
example, a Boolean, all we need to do is just go up to Variable Type in the Details
panel, select the dropdown, and then search for Level Sequence Actor, and you see
we have Level Sequence Actor, and we're going to select Object Reference.
And the next thing we'll do in our Details panel is ensure that our blueprint is
instanced editable.
So what this means is this variable that we've created will be exposed on our
blueprint when it's added to the level, meaning that we can change whatever this
is referencing per instance.
Let's go ahead and hit Compile.
And now what we're going to do is after our Set Actor Enable Collision, we are going
to create a new variable called, I'm sorry, not new variable, we're going to create
a new node called Play.
So if I do Play, uncheck Context Sensitive, and what I'm going to do is Play Sequence.
And what we're looking for is the Play, not Play Sequence, but Play.
And it should say Target is Movie Scene Sequence Player.
There we go.
And then I'm going to drag my Main Sequence off onto our Target, and you'll see that
it automatically creates our translator here.
So it's going to take our Main Sequence variable and plug it into the target of our
Play.
Perfect.
Let's go ahead and hit Compile.
And then the last thing that we need to do is create a Boolean variable called IsPlaying.
Now this variable is going to be used to check that the sequence is playing.
And we'll also be able to use this logic to pause gameplay or trigger other events
or logic.
Let's go back down to our variables.
Click our Plus.
I'm going to call this IsPlaying.
And we're going to change our Level Sequence Actor to a Boolean.
There we go.
We'll hit Compile and Save.
Now that our IsPlaying Boolean variable is created, we're going to drag and drop this
into the Event Graph.
And we're going to do the SetIsPlaying.
We'll go ahead and drag off of our Play, connect it, and then we're going to check
this that it is playing.
We're going to hit Compile and Save.
Now in the next section, we'll focus on pausing the actual sequence.